[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde à la une ce soir cette question
la france peut-elle échapper à un recond
finement 38 département bascule en
alerte maximale
annonce faite tout à l'heure par le
premier ministre jean castex le
couvre-feu touche désormais 54
départements et un territoire
d'outre-mer soit près de 46 millions de
personnes et les services de réanimation
se rapproche un peu plus chaque jour de
la saturation alors peut-on enrayer
cette seconde vague sans re confiné
c'est notre grand débat de ce soir
terrorisée et l'islamisme c'est le
nouveau mot d'ordre d' emmanuel macron
mais dans les faits il ya des règles à
respecter celle d'un état de droit
le gouvernement peut-il dissoudre aussi
facilement les associations islamistes
quels sont les obstacles juridiques et
constitutionnelles décryptage à suivre
et puis notre grand témoin ce soir axel
kahn président de la ligue nationale
contre le cancer on évoquera avec lui
l'opération octobre rose grande campagne
de dépistage du cancer du sein
et puis on parlera aussi avec lui de la
cacophonie du côté des scientifiques
depuis le début de la crise du coc vide
de tout cela on débat en plateau est de
votre côté n'hésitez pas à réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
sévère
[Musique]
bonsoir axel kahn et merci d'être avec
nous je le disais à l'instant à vous
êtes président de la ligue nationale
contre le cancer médecin généticien et
vous êtes notre grand témoin ce soir
pour commenter cette actualité très
riche à mes côtés également alexandre
mebazaa bonsoir vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris
julien aubert bonsoir vous êtes député
les républicains du vaucluse et
également par ailleurs membre de la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise
duco vidé puis sylvain maillard va nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants député
la république en marche de paris et
porte parole du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale on commence donc par se
pencher plus en détail sur les annonces
du premier ministre
les chiffres sont mauvais les courbes ne
s'inverse pas plusieurs département
bascule donc en alerte maximale
qui est concerné quelles conséquences
concrètes pour la population en voici en
détail avec julien galles nouveau tour
de vis annoncé par jean castex 38
départements supplémentaires et un
territoire d'outre-mer la polynésie
basculeront dès demain minuit en zone d'
alerte maximale au total à compter de
vendredi minuit ce sont 54 départements
et un territoire d'outre-mer qui seront
soumis à la règle du couvre-feu soit 46
millions de nos concitoyens
voici donc la nouvelle carte du
territoire concerné par un couvre feu de
six semaines
cela ne touche plus uniquement des
grandes métropoles mais aussi des
départements ruraux couvre-feu maintenu
entre 21h et 6h du matin et plutôt bien
respectée dans les zones déjà concernés
a précisé le premier ministre
durcissement des règles nécessaires pour
endiguer l'épidémie car selon jean
castex la situation sanitaire actuelle
est préoccupante avec une vitesse élevée
du virus
je vous le dis donc très clairement les
semaines qui viennent seront durs non
services hospitaliers vont être mis à
rude épreuve et le nombre de morts va
continuer d'augmenter les nouveaux cas
d'aujourd'hui sont les malades
hospitalisés de demain
malheureusement parfois les morts
d'après demain jean castex qui n'écarte
pas l'éventualité d'un reconfirme ans
j'en appelle donc encore et encore à la
solidarité nationale et à une
mobilisation sans faille car si nous ne
réussissons pas collectivement à juguler
l'épidémie
nous ferons face à une situation
dramatique et nous devrons envisager des
mesures beaucoup plus dures
les déclarations de jean castex le
premier ministre sylvain mayer nous a
rejoint bonsoir et merci d'être parmi
nous je pense par vous ou julien aubert
une petite tour de table sur ces
annonces du premier ministre on entendu
jean castex dire que des mesures
beaucoup plus dures seraient prises si
les cours ne s'inverse pas est ce qu'à
vos yeux
1re confinement est encore évitable
aujourd'hui en france évitables je crois
que ça va se jouer entre maintenant et
le 1er novembre
j'entends pas moi ce que je comprends je
dirais de ce que dit le premier ministre
c'est qu'ils attendent un début de
frémissement de signaux positifs qui
permettrait quelque part de considérer
que les mesures qui ont été prises
depuis maintenant un mois commence à
donner un effet mais comme il ya un
effet retard et que on a ensuite à
partir de décembre mois extrêmement
important pour la vie économique
je serai premier ministre je vous le
dirai la priorité c'est de faire en
sorte que sir confinement il ya ne le
fasse certainement pas entre le 1er
décembre et le 31 décembre parce que je
crois que l'économie ne s'en remettra
pas et donc je prendrai la date du 1er
novembre en dix ans le 1er novembre ça
c'est pas déstabiliser et bien dans ce
cas là est ce qu'il faudra pas passer à
la vitesse supérieure pour empêcher pour
empêcher qu'un mois plus tard le pire se
produise toujours dans ce dans cet
équilibre à trouver entre le risque
sanitaire est le risque est connu que
sylvain maillard de votre côté comment
vous voyez les choses quand vous
analysez analyser la situation
aujourd'hui
d'abord tout n'est pas figé on voit que
la situation est difficile
le premier ministre a annoncé une série
de mesures de couvre-feu dans bon nombre
de nouveaux départements
ce que l'on sait il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'on ne sait pas ce que l'on
sait c'est que on veut tout faire pour
éviter un recond finement et pour éviter
leur confinement évidemment le
couvre-feu est un élément moteur mais
aussi ses chacun d'entre nous de faire
en sorte de respecter les gestes
barrière de faire en sorte que chacun
d'entre nous fasse attention les uns aux
autres et vous avez le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui on harcèle ne font pas
attention prononcé dans la rue mais
roland dumas ne peut plus généreux ne on
ne peut pas généraliser on peut pas dire
et on fait mal ou on fait bien chacun
d'entre nous à cette responsabilité de
faire attention en permanence et donc je
dirais que notre destin ce qui va
arriver dans les semaines ou dans les
mois qui viennent dépend principalement
de nous on a cette première vague
difficile qui va arriver et qui est là
et qui va s'accentuer jusqu'au début
novembre ce que l'on espère c'est que le
couvre-feu permettent de limiter et
olivier ferrand la extrêmement bien dit
l'objectif il est d'essayer de revenir
le plus vite possible à 2,3 milles
contamination par jour pas plus pour
pouvoir maintenir une vie normale donc
je dirais les jours qui viennent en
fonction de notre comportement chacun
d'entre nous nous verrons l'évolution
axel kahn la réponse du gouvernement
elle vous semble adaptée et
proportionnée
aujourd'hui à dire vrai j'ai
l'impression que depuis le début de la
deuxième vague
le gouvernement est lâche et toujours
une semaine au moins en retard par
rapport à l'événement ce qui se passe
c'était vraiment prévisible et il y a
par exemple des décisions qui ont été
prises qui de mon point de vue d'un
point de vue sanitaire et même d'un
point de vue d'anciens présidents
d'université sont tout à fait
inexplicable que l'on ait fait rentrer
les universités avec des cours en
amphithéâtre alors que l'on sait très
bien que les jeux ak partout c'est pas
le cas dans le heureusement les
présidents d'université beaucoup d'entre
eux ont pris d'autres mesures mais il y
a encore pas mal de cours en présentiel
et je suis extrêmement concernés parce
que le nombre d'étudiants positif et
avec des signes cliniques est
extrêmement important et quand vous
regardez l'évolution de la maladie
depuis le mois d'août
depuis d'ailleurs le début août m
la fin juillet la chaîne de
contamination est très clair sont les
jeunes qui se contaminent d'abord en
vacances maintenant éventuellement à
l'université et puis ils contaminent les
parents parce que il les rencontre bien
évidemment d'autant plus qu'avec la
crise il y en a qui sont revenus en
famille et puis in fine et les
grands-parents et les populations les
plus fragiles et en suis très bien
l'évolution donc je crois que ça c'est
extrêmement peu compréhensible je
comprends bien pour l'école on pourra y
revenir
il y à d'autres mesures qui honnêtement
aurait permis d'atteindre l'objectif qui
nous est commun il faudrait éviter leur
confinement
parce qu'elles sont ces mesures selon
vous voilà or ça bon vous savez le ce
que l'on appelle le confinement nocturne
le couvre-feu c'est d'un confinement
nocture le confinement nocturne il a
exactement la même cible ceux qui
sortent pour s'éclater
le soir c'est avant tout les jeunes et
donc on considère que les jeunes étaient
au début de la chaîne de transmission
c'est eux éventuellement est évidemment
qu'ils font il faut éviter qu'ils ne se
contaminent et sur d'autres éléments il
ya une politique dont je conteste
vraiment la cohérence et je vous le dis
je le fais de ces deux niveaux qui est
celui de connaisseurs et d'épidémies qui
est en train de se développer est très
concerné parce que les malades atteints
du cancer sont concernés mais également
un ancien responsable de l'enseignement
supérieur présidents d'université de
presse etc
sylvain maillard d'un vous vouliez
réagir et après je vous donne la parole
oui j'entends j'entends ce que vous
pouvez dire le choix on a fait un choix
stratégique
le gouvernement est un choix qu'on
assume un que l'économie continue pour
pâques le le pays s'effondre
il faut que notre économie continue
deuxième chose laissez les transports
collectifs ouvert pour que chacun puisse
continuer à aller travailler puissent
continuer à aller à l'école et c'est mon
3ème point de laisser les écoles les
savoirs les points de savoir l'école les
collèges les lycées les universités
ouvertes parce que on ne veut pas de
casse sociale qu'à sociales cass
intellectuelle de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse continuer à apprendre en france
et que ce soit pas une année perdue ou
une génération un peu laissé de côté
et donc c'est une stratégie vous avez
raison rien ne sera est-ce que je suis
le départ dont je termine juste si vous
permettez professeur juste entre
il n'y a que des mauvaises décisions à
prendre et il ya que des mauvais choix
ferait affaire envoie en vérité à
l'heure actuelle il ya que des mauvais
choix le choix qui a été fait c'est tout
simplement de sur ces axes la de
privilégier la continuité de la vie et
tout ce qui est alex cette bulle social
de faire en sorte qu'elle soit la plus
réduite possible voilà alors simplement
en deux mots je suis d'accord avec tous
vos objectifs c'est la continuité de la
vie et donc une des conditions c'est la
minimisation de la chaîne de
transmission infectieuse car on sait
très bien ce qu'elle va devenir pour les
écoliers on sait très bien que le télé
enseignement à l'école et terriblement
discriminant pour les défavorisés
socialement terriblement c'est beaucoup
moins vrai dans les universités dans
l'enseignement supérieur
parce que le télé enseignement les mots
qui sont déjà extrêmement développée
quand j'étais présent d'université je
m'apprêtais avec la chaîne a fermé tout
mon université est évidemment a continué
l'enseignement pour les plus défavorisés
il y as possibilités on a suffisamment
dans les universités de postes pour leur
permettre avec la distanciation physique
nécessaire qu'il puisse néanmoins se
connecter des petits groupes et des
rencontres sont possibles
on est totalement incompréhensible c'est
cet élément là et je crois que ça
coûtait beaucoup de contamination
d'octobre mais bazar on a envie de vous
entendre d'abord sur cette question du
couvre-feu est ce que vous en valider le
principe est ce que vous jugez cela
efficace c'est ce qu'il aurait fallu le
décidé plus tôt
en tout cas on va savoir assez
rapidement si c'est efficace ou pas vous
entendez beaucoup de gens dire ça a été
efficace dans telle ou telle région le
seul test qu'on regarde tous en fait
c'est la guyane ou en trois quatre jours
on a vu la courbe s'infléchir en fait
aujourd'hui donc là ça voudrait dire que
par exemple sur paris et les autres
métropoles concernées dès le début par
le couvre-feu on pourrait voir une
inflexion rapide de la couronne le
premier chiffre qu'on va tous regarder
même s'il n'est pas à 100% correct c'est
le nombre de cas positifs alors il
dépend évidemment du nombre de personnes
qui vont se tester
il faut garder ça en tête mais si déjà
on voit une inflexion c'est à dire une
stabilisation en fait même pas une
baisse à une baisse se sera jamais avant
plusieurs semaines mais aujourd'hui le
premier maillon de la chaîne c'est quand
même les cas positifs moi je suis le
dernier maillon de la chaîne
qui est la réanimation et moi je
dépendent directement du nombre de cas
positifs parce que aujourd'hui dans ma
réanimation les malades qui viennent
c'est des malades qui vous raconte que
depuis une semaine dix jours ils ne sont
pas bien il respire mal ils savent très
bien comment ils ont été contaminées
dans telle ou telle réunion familiale ou
réunion même professionnel est en fait
ce qui est important c'est le message à
faire passer à tout le monde c'est que
vraiment il faut mettre le masque tout
le temps est le deuxième message médical
c'est que dès que vous avez de la fièvre
aller voir un médecin parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des bons chiffres
on a des meilleurs chiffres au mois de
mars parce que les gens viennent plus
tôt mais j'ai encore des malades dans
marine nations qui ont passé quinze
jours chez eux avant de venir donc
vraiment dès que vous avez de la fièvre
aller voir un médecin surtout maintenant
il ya la grippe et c'est compliqué de
faire la différence entre le co vider la
grille alors juste je reste avec vous
parce que on parle beaucoup de cette
seconde vague là depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours mais on a envie de
savoir concrètement ça se traduit
comment dans un service de réanimation
comme le vôtre aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
se passe d'écrire et nous la situation
est ce que c'est il identique à ce que
vous avez vécu au mois de mars
aucun rapport aucun rapport au mois de
mars dans jugèrent à peu près une
cinquantaine de lits de réanimation
entre saint louis et lariboisière
j'avais à cinq malades près j'avais que
des malades qu vides et des malades
qu'ovide lourd qui venait à la dernière
seconde et en plus moi je suis dans le
nord de paris salué lariboisière donc on
recevait les malades de zones qui n'ont
pas beaucoup d'hôpitaux et des malades
dans les caractéristiques sont horribles
et on a les mêmes aujourd'hui c'est à
dire des gens plutôt de 40 ans 50 ans 60
ans obèse hypertendus alors
l'hypertension c'est tout le temps et
des gens qui sont pour beaucoup précaire
c'est à dire qu'ils habitent dans des
logements où vous comprenez facilement
que le le passage du virus se fait très
facilement
donc c'est vraiment la même typologie
qu'on a aujourd'hui
la différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
quelques malades qui arrive assez tôt
pour avoir le médecin généraliste puis
les médecins à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
qu'ils puissent commencer à leur donner
des traitements il ya deux traitements
qui ont vraiment permis de changer les
choses c'est les corticoïdes assez tôt
et les anticoagulants il faut se
souvenir que c'est la france et même
l'hôpital lariboisière qui était parmi
les premiers à dire que l'embolie
pulmonaire était un facteur de risque
gravissime et ça
ç'a permis d'aider mais malgré ça on
encore des malades qui viennent tard et
qui finissent bas comme j'en ai eu
encore aujourd'hui et qui finissent
malheureusement par être passé sous
ventilateur et quand on passe aux
ventilateurs c'est ça le message qu'il
faut retenir
malheureusement le risque de décès il
est de 1 pour toi un pour trois et quel
que soit l'âge et quel que soit l'âge et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut que le premier
maillon de la chaîne soit vraiment
parfait il faut qu'on parte du premier
maillon de la chaîne
juste pour bien comprendre quand vous
dites ça n'a rien à voir avec la
première vague ça veut dire que quoi
l'état des patients qui arrivent chez
vous et moins moins inquiétant à que
j'avais 95% de co vide aujourd'hui le
pari que tous les médecins que tous les
réanimateurs veulent tenir c'est qu'on
puisse en même temps avoir d'écho vide
et avoir tous les malades de la
population française qu'on a d'habitude
c'est à dire les attaques cardiaques les
que les attaques cérébrales
les femmes qui accouchent et ça se passe
mal les des dysfonction rénale qui
s'aggrave ça c'est mon ombre mon
quotidien de tous les jours et ces
malades là moi je souhaite continuer de
les traiter on souhaite tous les traiter
en même temps que l'écho vite et ça
aujourd'hui c'est le problème d'eau
quand on dit dans quelques jours on va
avoir une tension
non nous la tension on l'a dès
aujourd'hui et on espère ne pas avoir
faire faire un choix est ce pour ça
qu'on espère que le couvre-feu va
permettre d'aplanir la courbe pour ne
pas qu'on ait à faire un choix
à âge égal entre quelqu'un qui vient de
faire une attaque cardiaque et quelques
quelques vite c'est bien d'ailleurs moi
j'ai envie de vous entendre sur ce qu'a
dit le professeur delfraissy c'était le
9 septembre dernier on rappelle lé
président du conseil scientifique et il
avait dit à l'époque que le gouvernement
allait être obligé de prendre des
mesures difficiles un certain nombre de
décisions difficiles dans les huit à dix
jours maximum c'est à dire avant le 19
septembre à l'époque est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas fallu les prendre cette
décision
quand on voit rétrospectivement vous
allez me dire c'est facile la situation
aujourd'hui vous faites vous ai déjà
fait votre la réponse est oui là mais en
attendant il était là pour conseiller le
gouvernement s'était maison mais c'est
son rôle
et après il ya des choix politiques qui
sont fait le choix politique et c'est
vrai quand on regarde dans le
rétroviseur c'est toujours un peu plus
facile mais les choix politiques de
faire un couvre-feu ça veut dire que
vous condamnez tout un pan de notre
économie c'est-à-dire les bars les
restaurants les salles de sport les
théâtres et cinémas
tout ça c'est que vous les condamnez à
court terme a évidemment fait on fait
des mesures pour les accompagner mais
mais c'est extrêmement difficile et une
partie d'entre eux ne rouvriront pas et
donc au moment où vous devez prendre la
décision d'un couvre-feu vous dire que
votre main elle tremble ou savent
exactement quels sont les conseils
donc c'est normal que l'autorité
sanitaire donne son avis et ensuite
c'est aux politiques de trancher
moi je fais confiance au gouvernement je
crois qu il analysé l'ensemble aussi de
des difficultés sociales parce qu'on
parle des difficultés sanitaires mais
c'était extrêmement difficile de faire
un couvre-feu et 2 et 2 et le pari
collectif de chacun d'entre nous de
faire extrêmement attention pour que ce
couvre-feu soit la barrière ultime est
que nous n'ayons pas à les arts confinés
derrière c'est un pari c'est vrai on a
on ne connaît pas l'issue moi j'ai assez
confiant sur le fait qu'on puisse dans
le coup et trouver une issue favorable
aux coureurs
julien aubert vous vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ou vous pensez qu'il aurait
fallu apprendre plus tôt si je crois si
vous voulez que le c'est difficile de
prévoir les incertitudes et personne
n'est 2 1
le gouvernement a fait un pari pour moi
qui était de dire il ya eu une première
vague et puis on n'aura pas forcément un
automne très compliqué on va pour
revenir à une une vie économique normale
et d'ailleurs ça s'est vu dans les
annonces avec le plan de relance avec
voilà ça y est on est sorti du creux
vide
très rapidement il a été rattrapé par
quelque chose qui commençait à
ressembler à une deuxième vague alors je
suis pas un expert médical mais sinon
j'ai compris c'est que en réalité elle
était moins haute que la première mais
quand même qu'elle existe et que le taux
de mortalité était inférieure parce
qu'on a fait des progrès sur cette
technique est que en fait part on avait
un nombre de contaminés qui était deux
fois inférieur et un nombre de morts qui
étaient environ deux fois inférieur mais
c'est peut-être une 2000 vague mais ça
reste quand même une deuxième vague
après par rapport à ça on va dire qu'il
ya des critiques on peut faire
premièrement les français sont pas tous
des experts médicaux
donc ils sont très attachés la question
de l'égalité et donc ils veulent
comprendre pourquoi le cinéma est fermé
mais l'assemblée nationale est ouverte
pourquoi le restaurant est ouvert à midi
et il n'est pas ouvert le soir je crois
qu'on a manqué de pédagogie médicale
pour expliquer par exemple que dans un
bar on crie parce qu'elle est en bois il
y ait du bruit donc on projette
peut-être plus loin les germes encore je
ne suis pas médecin je vous dis ce que
j'ai compris
mais gérer qu'un premier sujet parce que
parce que la population peut pas adhérer
à des mesures qu'elle ne comprend pas
premièrement et puis deuxièmement quand
on dit
couvre feu c'est pour les jeunes n'y a
pas que les jeunes qui sortent la nuit
il ya beaucoup de gens dont pour eux
leur travail c'est la nuit le taxi banat
taxi commence à 18h maintenant c'est
court enfin 21h le type vous le tuer
parce que peut-être qu'ils sont taxi il
le partage avec un autre taxi qui fait
le matin bon deuxièmement il ya la
question des tests alors sur les tests
effectivement on a mis en place un
système mais là encore il ya pas de
logique
quand vous faites testez vous mettez 48
heures au 112 heures avant d'avoir votre
rendez vous donc vous sentez pas très
bien deuxièmement on veut tester qu'on
vous dit vous n'allez pas encore avoir
tout être trop quatre jours avant
d'avoir le résultat
ben finalement ils ont causé de passer à
travers cette espèce des profs
d'obstacles vous dit j'aurais mieux fait
de m'isoler une semaine directement à la
maison parce que dans dans la semaine
qui s'est écoulée j'ai rencontré plein
de gens j'ai fait là que j'ai été dans
des lieux qui étaient contaminés et ça
je pense que ça n'a pas aidé si vous
voulez dans la lutte contre le virus et
puis enfin il ya le problème de mettre
une norme qui frappe tout le monde ce
qui se comporte bien ce qui se comporte
mal il ya des bars qui ont fait
respecter la distanciation sociale il ya
des restaurants qui ont fait respecter
la distanciation sociale il y en a où ça
c'est ça n'a pas été le cas
on les a tous punis et je crois que ça
c'est un petit poème politique c'est que
celui qui a fait des efforts celui qui
donne le nom celui qui a régulièrement
nié ses clients il faut mettre le masque
la lui il est puni comme les autres et
ça je crois que c'est très dur parce que
comme on approche maintenant sur 2021 on
va voir les premiers effets véritables
de la crise économique
eh bien vous avez à la fois l'impatience
la peur et puis le sentiment quelque
part des deux lâché par le gouverneur
voulaient réagir
moi j'entends ce que dit mon collègue
aubert la seule chose c'est qu'il faut
une règle claire si on commence à
rentrer dans diverses règles plus
compliqué dans ça ne fonctionne pas il
n'y a pas d'adhésion
la seule chose c'est que évidemment nous
mettons à l'arrêt une partie de nos
entreprises
les bars les restaurants les salles de
sport les théâtres les cinémas
il faut les accompagner nous ce que nous
sommes là et nous serons là pour les
accompagner parce qu'on a besoin de moi
je suis député paris imaginez paris sans
ses bars et restaurants ses cinémas ses
théâtres
ce n'est pas possible donc il faut faire
en sorte et ça c'est la responsabilité
du gouvernement et de la majorité
d'accompagner les mesures pour les aider
à survivre pendant 7
difficile avec cette jeune et robert
évoqué un manque de pédagogie médical
pour bien faire comprendre les décisions
prises à l'ensemble de la population
est ce que cette pédagogie a fait défaut
ou est-ce que c'est pas plutôt l'intérêt
économique aussi qui a primé par moments
sur le sanitaire que l'intérêt
économique soit présent un très haut
niveau c'est normal et on est tous
obsédés par le risque d'une aggravation
considérable de la passe économique très
difficile il ya aucun problème aucun
d'entre nous on va dire noeuds 120 qu'on
avait nommé sa dans sa poche avec son
mouchoir par dessus aucun mais on me
propose pas ce que mais le problème est
de savoir comment on fait comment on
fait le pire pour l'économie c'est leur
confinement
mais d'un autre côté leur confinement
celui des deux mois du printemps a été
redoutable mans efficace remarquablement
efficace d'ailleurs dans tous les pays
quand vous confiné vous arrêter la
circulation du virus a aucun promet
aujourd'hui certains pays recond fini
pour deux semaines à l'irlande sa
décision le aimé aller à lège et quand
on parle d'une insuffisance de pédagogie
la principale insuffisance de pédagogie
ça a été dans l'insuffisance de suivi du
déconfinement le confinement a été
remarquablement respecté par les
français ils ont été héroïques
j'ai des raisons presque fait aussi bien
que les chinois alors que nous on est
une démocratie quand même et c'est bien
on en est fier mais ensuite on n'a pas
assez dit en français vous avez réussi
le niveau 2 circulation du virus est
très bas mais y circulent
et on l'a dit naturellement mais pas
beaucoup et il y a eu un relâchement
considérable au moment où naturellement
les français avaient besoin d'aspirer
une grande bouffée d'air frais de
s'éclater pour tout dire après le
confinement et cela dans toute la france
c'est à dire qu'ils sont pas regardants
quand elles n'ont qu on a nationalisé
ce faible niveau de circulation puis à
ce que l'on accueille selon qu'on
connaît j'étais totalement prévisibles
les jeunes gens contaminés les moins
jeunes puis les gg les genres de 20 juin
et ça va je suis juste répondre quelque
chose bruno le maire lorsqu'il ya eu les
arbitres h le couvre-feu et leur
confinement était arrivé que des études
qui montrait que le couvre-feu coûté
finalement plus chaque leur confinement
et je voulais dire tout à l'heure parce
que je suis du vaucluse qui vient d'être
confiné quand on a fait un confinement
dans un petit village où il ya un
commerce c'est pas exactement le même
risque
surtout quand vous avez zéro cas
positifs testé que avignon or en fait il
voulait on applique exactement la même
chose pour le département et je pense
qu'à un moment donné c'est pas en
vitrifiant si vous voulez la ruralité
qu'on se portera mieux parce que les
enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes les
interactions sociales ne sont pas les
mêmes enfin un sujet il ya l'économie
il ya la médecine est quand même un
sujet qui sert aussi à équilibrer le
débat qui sont les libertés
individuelles
moi je connais beaucoup de français qui
estime qu' on va trop loin c'est que
l'état a la qualité possible dépossède
de leur liberté d'aller et venir et ne
le comprennent pas et il est il proteste
alors après ils ont le peut-être tort
médicalement mais politiquement ce qui
s'est passé au printemps avec un
parlement à l'arrêt avec je dirais des
incursions sur la liberté individuelle
n'est pas anodin au plan démocratique
juste docteur mebazaa moi j'ai envie de
savoir aussi sont à tirer pleinement les
leçons de cette première vague comment
ça se passe pour vous à l'hôpital par
rapport à tout ce qui a fait défaut lors
de la première vague est ce que vous
manquait encore de matériels
d'équipements de protection
est-ce que vous manquez de curare comme
ça a été un moment évoquée ou est-ce
qu'on en ait dans la reconstitution de
tous ses stocks
comment ça se passe pour vous alors
aujourd'hui partout en france il ya les
stocks qu'il faut mehdi stocks pour
quelques semaines donc on n'a pas des
stocks qui sont là pour six mois une
année donc il faut ça il faut le savoir
au point de vue du personnel moi je suis
j'entends certains chefs de service qui
disent mon personnel est fatigué moi
j'ai beaucoup de chance dans les
réanimations que je dirige
on a encore des infirmiers très
courageux des aides soignants très
courageux et qui justement se bat avec
nous pour qu'on puisse garder ces deux
sources de patience c'est à dire l'écho
vides et les noms qu vie d'un jeu
rappelle qu' on a cette expertise les
infirmiers les aides soignants en à
cette expertise pour les attaques
cardiaques et cérébrales donc le
matériel ça va le les malades on va
essayer de prendre un maximum mais il
faut absolument qu'on comprenne quand
est-ce que ce flux parce qu'on reçoit en
plus les malades par vagues
avant-hier on a reçu 3 qu'ovide en même
temps très très grave donc ce qu'il faut
c'est que vraiment c'est vague là
s'arrête pour qu'on puisse s'occuper des
malades qu'on a aujourd'hui en
réanimation vous quand on entend avec
cette can tirer le bilan du
confinement du premier confinement on
s'est dit mais pourquoi pas reconfirmer
pour deux semaines si c'est aussi
efficace que cela qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous écoutez moi je ne suis pas
expert du confinement du couvre feu
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que tout
le monde a vu que le confinement du
premier coup a bien marché le couvre-feu
ce que ça va marcher ou pas je ne sais
pas mais nous on a absolument besoin de
s'occuper des malades n'ont qu vide il
faut que les malades qu'ovide vraiment
ça s'arrête ça diminue et on a
aujourd'hui les moyens pour s'en occuper
mais je rappelle qu'à 30% 40% qui meurt
et c'est terrible et je peux vous
assurer que c'est pas des personnes
âgées
c'est des gens qui sont jeunes qui
arrivent tard mais qu'ils sont jeunes il
faut que ça s'arrête le souhaitais c'est
à la racine en situation d'obésité ou du
jeu ne l'a une grande partie sont il ya
les trois caractéristiques c'est
d'écarter six social c'est la précarité
et c'est obésité hypertension artérielle
et de diabète
c'est vraiment la juge larry klayman et
là j'ai évidemment et là j'ai évidemment
mais par exemple aujourd'hui en
réanimation en france mais c'est lé cas
dans l'ensemble de l'europe
ce qu'on appelle la médiane est à 60 ans
c'est à dire que la moitié des malades
hospitalisés en réanimation hospitalisé
à 60 ans or effectivement
malheureusement les personnes âgées ont
ce qu'on appelle les comorbidités des
maladies chroniques
mais vous savez quand vous êtes en
réanimation tout tout est possible
pouvait avoir la petite infection
pulmonaire vous attendez pas le cathéter
qui fait l hôtel chose donc vraiment
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on garde en tête
ces vins maillard fait juste réagir
pardon c'est extrêmement important ce
que vous venez dire et sa défaite permet
à l'ensemble des téléspectateurs de bien
situer ce que vous avez comme patient à
l'heure actuelle je vois juste ravir ce
que dit mon collègue aubert je crois
qu'il a mal compris les propos de bruno
le maire évidemment un couvre-feu coûte
beaucoup moins cher à l'état et à la
sécurité sociale que une fermeture
totale faut que les rapports sont de 1 à
4 donc évidemment d'un point de vue
économique et d'un point de vue social
il faut mieux un couvre-feu et chacun
puisse faire en sorte que qu'il
fonctionne plutôt qu un recond finement
où il ya beaucoup plus de casse et
économique et social donc là je voulais
juste pas laisser passer ça je pense à
une injection de c'est peut-être jamais
vu
j'ai vu l'information inverse je veux
bien croire mon collègue pour une fois
un mot rapide chéreau de la femme en de
liberté qui est un principe sur lequel
en tant qu éthiciens dans le domaine
médical sur lequel musique plancher
depuis très très longtemps
il y a depuis très longtemps une
exception dans le domaine de l'exercice
des libertés individuelles qui sont les
urgences sanitaires les maladies à
déclaration obligatoire les lazarets les
confinements oran que décrit camus
depuis très longtemps et cela parce
qu'une des grandes caractéristiques de
la liberté vous le savez bien c'est que
ça limite est le moment parfait duquel
te nuire à celle d'autrui
alors les gens ils sont libres de n'être
pas infecté je veux dire que quelqu'un
peut être libre de n'être pas affecté de
ne pas rentrer en réanimation ne pas
risquer de mourir si bien que des
restrictions de libertés individuelles
dont le but est de d'éviter ces
contaminations
c'est tout à fait dans l'esprit des
pères de la république et de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
je connais peu de cas dans l'histoire où
un gouvernement ami pendant deux mois 65
millions et toute sa population sous clé
sans un débat au parlement non je ne
parle pas du débat honnêtement mais
comme vous le savez très bien
il y a eu deux milliards de personnes
qui ont été confinés en même temps c'est
à dire que tous nos morts alors vous
allez vous avez ce week-end julie robert
puisque ce week-end vous avait siégé
pour débattre de la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et ça va ça va évidemment faire l'objet
d'un débat avec les députés merci à tous
les trois d'être venu sur notre plateau
axel kahn vous restez avec nous parce
que dans un instant on va évoquer votre
autre actualité mais d'abord on ne se
penche sur ma journée à l'assemblée qui
compte y est consacrée justement à cette
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est bien cela thomas des
prêts oui exactement clément un projet
de loi qui prévoit d'étendre jusqu'en
février 2021 l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais qui divise beaucoup au sein des
députés je vous raconte tout ça
alors dans son intervention à la
télévision la semaine dernière emmanuel
macron a annoncé le retour de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans tout le pays en
état d'urgence qui permet notamment la
mise en place du couvre feu
mais pour prolonger à cet état d'urgence
il faut passer par le parlement
le parlement qui examine depuis ce matin
ce texte qui prévoit notamment
d'allonger cet état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 16 février inclus
mais surtout de mettre en place une
période de transition jusqu'au 1er avril
et c'est ce temps qui inquiète de
nombreux parlementaires qui ont
l'impression qu'on leur privent leur
pouvoir de voter la loi donner des
moyens c'est une chose sur une bonne
base juridique
oui mais deux sur une durée limitée là
nous nous sentons privé le parlement
privé d'une partie de son action avec un
quasi blanc ça jusqu'au 1er avril
peut-on accepter de le faire sur une
durée aussi longue
là vous proposer quelque chose qui
exclut totalement le parlement pour une
durée trop longue c'est le pouvoir
législatif qui sera à l'arrêt ça nous
paraît pas juste du point de vue
démocratique mais surtout ça ne paraît
pas juste du point de vue l'objectif
commun qui devrait être un autre de
fabriquer sans cesse dans cette période
de crise de l'unité nationale par le
débat démocratique
bonjour sacha ollier est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas été plus consensuel de
faire un état d'urgence plus courts afin
de revenir plus régulièrement devant les
députés
nous avons besoin d'un texte qui soit
suffisamment robuste ce suffisamment
long pour avoir une incidence réelle sur
le niveau d'occupation dans les hôpitaux
parce qu'on a dans les hôpitaux des
agents qui sont éprouvés fatigue est
sollicité et qui vont avoir aussi besoin
de tourner face à l'afflux de malades
que nous connaissons mais ne nous
flageller l'ont pas nous sommes l'un des
parlements européens sinon le parlement
européen qui est le plus consulté et qui
a le plus à regarder la situation et les
décisions qui peuvent être prises par le
gouvernement
mais ce matin tous les groupes de
l'opposition presque les républicains
les communistes le parti socialiste même
lui dit on ce sentiment d'être
dépossédés de leur pouvoir de députés
vous les comprenez qu'on ait ce débat
c'est absolument normal que le parlement
que le gouvernement cherche à obtenir
une
des moyens en tout cas une période
d'état d'urgence un tiers qui soit
satisfaisante c'est aussi normal c'est
le débat démocratique et c'est pour ça
que en responsabilité nous nous visons
quatre mois dans l'état dans lequel nous
sommes
c'est pas forcément excessif ou en tout
cas manifestement disproportionnée par
rapport aux enjeux qui sont devant nous
enfin très honnêtement on a un pays qui
peut prendre une pente très glissante et
là c'est à nous de dire en
responsabilité
on donne les moyens de que de ne pas
prendre cette plante là voilà clément ce
texte qui prolonge l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sera présenté dans l'hémicycle
à partir de samedi matin et ce sera à
suivre en direct sur lcp
notre grand témoin à présent et on va
parler avec vous axel kahn dieu
dépistage du cancer du sein avec cette
semaine selon moi pardon octobre rose
qui est consacrée à la prévention au
dépistage à la sensibilisation au cancer
du sein
malheureusement on va voir avec vous que
la crise sanitaire elle a aussi des
conséquences dans ce domaine mais
d'abord d'un mourant quelques chiffres
on en est où
dans le combat contre le cancer du sein
en france aujourd'hui il y a environ 58
milles cancer du sein chez les femmes
chaque année chez le plus fréquent des
cancers féminins
heureusement le traitement a fait de
très gros progrès et il y à douze mille
morts donc vous faites le pourcentage un
cancer du sein qui est détectée
lorsqu'il est de petite taille qui n'a
pas encore envahi les tissus
environnants non plus que les ganglions
et d'errer dans 95% des cas en
n'épargnant le sein en enlevant la
tumeur en faisant une radiothérapie pas
de chimiothérapie et donc rien il ya un
enjeu dans le dépistage marrer quand
j'ai vu ça mental c'est de pouvoir
détecter les cancers
à ce stade là au moment où ils sont
presque toujours guéri et avec des
moyens qui ne sont pas exagérés et c'est
là où il ya un problème qui se pose en
particulier cette année puisqu'il y à
cet impact qu'a eue le confinement sur
le dépistage du cancer du sein est ce
qu'on a réussi à mesurer un peu cet
impact
un oui très bien
durant la période de printemps le
dépistage systématique a été stoppée en
réalité ils étaient stoppées deux
milieux marche du 17 mars jusqu'en juin
il a repris à partir de juin et les
femmes elles mêmes les autres personnes
susceptibles d'avoir le cancer se sont
ré frein d'aller à l'hôpital parce
qu'ils avaient peur d'être contaminés
peur de déranger et cetera et cetera ps
que se rôder dans cette période
on s'attendait à dépister tous cancers
confondus 60000 cancer environ et on en
a détecté on a là des pistes et que
30000 donc il y a un manque à gagner de
en cancer de 50%
et si le retard n'est que de 2 3 mois
c'est pas dramatique mais le rappel ce
retard de bien voilà il n'a pas été
rattrapé
il n'a pas été rattrapé parce que les
dépistages ont repris tard parce que
effectivement ils ont repris mais pas
suffisamment pour rattraper également le
retard et que à nouveau comme on en a
parlé tout à l'heure la situation se
tend donc maintenant il y à des retards
qui vont être de cinq chinois et des
retards de 5 6 mois ce sont des chances
qui sont perdus et sont des vies qui le
seront également
et donc nous sommes extrêmement inquiets
de ce point de vue là d'un mot quel
bilan vous voudrez c'est de ce mois
d'octobre rose cette année où on en est
des dons notamment alors sans parler des
dons c'est la mobilisation
il y à un message la ligue essaye
d'aller vraiment partout avec d'autres
partenaires
en dix ans aujourd'hui vraiment mesdames
le danger pour vous c'est de ne pas vous
faire dépister détecter soigner aussitôt
que possible votre cancer
il y à des précautions très importantes
qui sont prises lorsque vous allez
consulter lorsque vous faites une
mammographie et c est donc le danger
principal c'est la non le nom diagnostic
à notre connaissance du cancer il faut
qu'en masse réellement nous éviter ce
danger là le cancer globalement c'est un
adversaire bien plus méchant et
dangereux que ne l'est la co vide
ok mais on va justement abordé cette
autre question de l'aco vide avec vous
depuis début de cette crise on a vu la
communauté scientifique se divisait en
deux camps si l'on peut dire d'un côté
les rassure east de l'autre les
alarmistes avec pour résultat une
cacophonie alors j'aimerais vous faire
agira à cette situation inédite d'une
communauté scientifique qui se déchire
publiquement mais d'abord le rappel des
faits avec maïté frémont mettez deux
épidémiologistes sur un plateau télé et
vous obtiendrez un débat enflammé le dit
tous les textes étaient nominés que la
seconde vague c'était de la pure fiction
gelé les avoirs et majorité qu'il va y
avoir un plateau alors c'est ce que je
dis depuis 20 mois
je remet en jeu c'est à dire je faisais
du supportable
ici ce ne sont pas deux hommes
politiques en pleine campagne mais bel
et bien deux médecins aux idées
diamétralement opposées cette guerre des
blouses blanches dure depuis des mois
dans la presse et des centaines de
millions de français qui n'en peuvent
plus de ces dissensions entre les
scientifiques à qui on dit tout et
n'importe quoi tous les jours je veux
sur y en a ras-le-bol derrière nos
petits écrans
deux camps s'opposent il y a ceux qu'on
appelle les alarmistes
parmi eux les infectiologues eric com ou
encore karine lacombe des médecins qui
réclament des durcissements des mesures
et qui insiste sur la gravité de la
situation on sait que le virus revient
on voit partout sur le territoire
français une augmentation du nombre de
cas notamment d'hospitalisation de
réanimation à des degrés différents
et puis il ya ceux qu'on surnomme les
rassure east eux dénoncent une psychose
autour du coronavirus la menace à
l'heure actuelle n'existe pas et on love
on la fabrique le chef de file des rats
sur east dira même dans les colonnes de
l'express
nous contestons cette histoire de
deuxième vague du coc vide qui
correspond à une rhétorique anxiogène
mais le tout premier c'est lui didier
rahout et pour son audition à
l'assemblée ce microbiologiste explique
sa position
j'ai pensé que je pouvais être utile
dans cette liste parce que je je je je
je crois que j'ai une expérience qui est
extrême dans ce domaine là et j'essaie
de le faire à chaque fois comme je
pouvais mais comment se fait-il que deux
camps s'affrontent ainsi on est allé
demander à l'auteur d'un rapport sur la
crise sanitaire en france
et pour lui la réponse se trouverait
dans la définition de leur domaine
d'expertisé dans le domaine des maladies
infectieuses qui est un domaine
extrêmement vaste
vous avez typiquement les
microbiologistes les gens qui sont
capables de détecter les microbes et qui
travaille essentiellement dans des
laboratoires vous avez les spécialistes
du terrain dans le domaine des soins aux
patients qui sont les médecins
infectiologues qui traitent des malades
et puis vous avez les épidémiologistes
qui eux sont plutôt ceux qui traitent
les chiffres qui comprennent les
chiffres et qui au fond sont capables de
mieux comprendre ce qui est en train de
se passer en termes d'épidémiologie
malheureusement aujourd'hui on vit une
période que l'om est ce d'ailleurs
intitulé une période d'infos d'amy et
finalement vous savez le propre d'un
expert d'un véritable expert c'est qu'en
fait il m'est toujours de doute le doute
dans ce qu'il dit alors que le nom
experts lui il affirme en fonction de
leur spécialité tous n'ont pas la même
vision
mais au delà de la vérité scientifique
ils sont tous liés au serment
d'hippocrate qui dit jeu
n'entreprendrait rien qui dépasse mes
compétences alors axel kahn vous avez
dénoncé récemment je cite la brochette
d'abrutis qui disent que rien ne se
passe donc si on reprend la typologie de
maïté frémont j'en déduis que vous
n'êtes plus alarmiste que rassure east
non non je suis pas alarmiste je suis
réaliste
c'est à dire qu'est ce que je dis depuis
un certain temps je dit écoutez il y à
une évolution que l'on peut très bien
quantifier que l'on peut très bien
projetée qui est inquiétante et il y a
un début de deuxième vague
je suis le président de la ligue contre
le cancer on a des combien les personnes
atteintes de cancer étaient des victimes
collatérales
je suis totalement mobilisés alors quand
des personnes disent non seulement il
n'y a rien mais ne prenez pas de
précaution est bien évident le résultat
c'est que les gens ne prennent pas de
précautions que la gravité de la vague
augmente et que notamment les gens dont
je suis co responsable en tant que
président de la ligue sont encore plus
menacés et comme aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas photo
nous avons parlé de ce qui était
exigible du fait de l'importance de la
deuxième vague
je suis obligé de dire que ces personnes
qui parlaient comme cela face à
l'évidence c'est pas très méchant
effectivement se sont comportés comme
des abrutis c'est le cas par exemple du
professeur raoul tavaux yeux nos raul
c'est tout à fait différent
d'abord au départ le pru le professeur
raoul tu as eu une intuition d'un
traitement qui n'était pas illogique et
dans lequel j'ai espéré comme tout le
monde il a fait une erreur très
importante c'est qu'il a été tellement
sûr de lui qu'il n'a pas soumis son
traitement à ce qui est le standard
vraiment des progrès médicaux en matière
d'essais thérapeutiques
c'est à dire un essai contre les ne l'a
pas fait et rapidement pas rapidement il
est apparu que c'était totalement
inefficace à quelques stades de la
maladie que ce soit et ça fait
énormément de mal dans le monde entier
dans le monde entier ça fait énormément
de mal
les deux pays dont les présidents ont
pris eux mêmes le médicament et en on
fait vraiment la promotion sont les
états unis d'amérique et le brésil parmi
les deux pays du monde où le nombre de
morts par million d'habitants est de
loin le plus important
allez on passe au décryptage à présent
j'ai été très heurté que nous
n'arrivions pas alors on attend
jingle peut-être peut-être pas on va
voir alors emmanuel emmanuel macron a
décidé je cite de terroriser l'islamisme
après l'assassinât du professeur samuel
bâtiment va voir que les choses ne sont
pas si simple quand on vit dans un état
de droit avec nous pour discuter de tout
cela
laurence vichnievsky bonsoir vous êtes
député modem du puy de dôme et également
ancienne magistrate pierre conessa
bonsoir vous êtes ancien haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de la défense
et et vous connaissez bien ces
différentes problématiques qu'on va
aborder avec vous et on commence par
vous stéphane blakowski bon sort clément
[Musique]
alors ses fans si j'ai bien compris si
j'ai bien compris clairement le
gouvernement a décidé de taper vite et
fort contre l'islam radical alors pour
bien prouver sa détermination notre
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
a publié un tweet hier un peu façon
donald trump en dénonçant précisément
deux associations qu'il avait
l'intention de dissoudre on voit le
tweet qui s'affiche ici voyez le ccf et
baraka city donc si je vous comprends
bien ces deux associations devraient
être rapidement 10 août devrait alors
vous faites d'après le conditionnel
clément passer un si c'était aussi
simple que ça de dissoudre le ccf
on peut imaginer que le gouvernement
leur effet dès hier au conseil des
ministres aurait annoncé cette
dissolution or hier au conseil des
ministres le porte-parole du
gouvernement a bien annoncé une
dissolution
mais nice est lisse et seief ni celle
des braques à city en écoute gabriela
talent nous avons ce matin à prononcer
la dissolution du collectif cheikh
yacine impliqué lié à l'attentât de
vendredi dernier et depuis bien
longtemps
le faux nez d'une idéologie anti
républicaine qui diffuse alors ses fans
pourquoi ne pas avoir annoncé dès hier
la dissolution du cc alors le ministre
de l'intérieur est un homme très
puissant
malheureusement pour lui il doit malgré
tout se soumettre à la loi c'est comme
ça en france et donc là avec la loi
quand on dort on tape on ne sait pas si
simple de dissoudre une association peut
prendre un exemple qui date de l'an
dernier l'an dernier le gouvernement
s'était mis en tête de dissoudre
l'association génération identitaire en
génération une association pardon
d'extrême droite
il y avait même des articles dans la
presse qui parlait de ce projet et puis
finalement ils ont fait une étude
juridique des motifs qui pourraient
permettre de dissoudre cette association
et puis comme il n'avait pas qu'il soit
très très solide après avoir eu un effet
d'annoncé bas ils ont dû y renoncer
aujourd'hui génération identitaire
existe toujours ils ont ils ont pignon
sur rue est ce que ça veut dire qu'on
risque de vivre la même chose avec le
ccf en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
le gouvernement il doit bien bien
réfléchir au motif qu'il a l'intention
d'invoquer pour dessoude dissoudre le
ccf parce que si sa décision et validé
par la justice à la ccl l'immunisation
c'est évidemment très contre-productif
tongs et pourtant ces deux choses qui
peuvent arriver un exemple qui date de
à l'époque le préfet dessoude après
toulouse de dissoudre une école
coranique hors contrat où il y avait des
gens qui étaient fichés s qui donnait
des cours
donc ça paraît une mesure de bon sens
sauf que deux ans plus tard qu'est ce
qui se passe bien l'école a fait appel
et la cour d'appel de toulouse annulent
la décision et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui cette école est toujours
ouverte simplement changé de nom et elle
continue de fonctionner alors si le
gouvernement se retrouve dans ce cas de
figure qu'est ce qui peut faire si la
loi ne plaît pas au gouvernement qu
est-ce qui fait ils essaient de la
changer de cd rendre ce qui va faire il
ya un projet de loi qui va être examiné
à partir du 9 décembre l'assemblée dans
la loi contre le séparatisme
mais il y avait même des lois qui serait
assez délicate de changer sans créer de
vrais polémique en définitive mais
j'imagine que vous avez quelques
exemples à nous donner et bien vu j'ai
toujours mon petit exemple sous le coude
clément donc par exemple darmanin
propose d'expulser les étrangers en
situation régulière qui vivent en france
alors qu'eux ils sont fichés nous pour
l'islam radical donc ça paraît une
mesure de bon sens vois pas trop qui
pourraient s'y opposer mais c'est pas si
simple
je vous prends un exemple celui d'un
garçon qui s'appelle un homme qui
s'appelle kamel daoudi donc un algérien
qui a été condamné pour terrorisme qui
on a retiré la nationalité et qui
maintenant est interdit de territoire on
est typiquement le gars qui kyi devrait
être expulsé
sauf que la loi en france et c'est
marqué dans cet article du monde
n'autorise pas à son expulsion parce que
si on expulse en algérie ils risquent
d'être soumis à la torture dont voyez
c'est la question qu'on se pose toujours
dans ce débat là est ce qu'il faut
s'affranchir de l'état de droit pour
être
plus efficace dans la lutte contre
l'islam et bien vous posez parfaitement
les termes et je me tourne vers vous
pour commencer laurence vichnievsky
quand on entend stéphane blakowski et
est ce que vous ne vous dites pas que le
gouvernement allait un petit peu vite en
besogne est ce qui prend pas un risque
de se faire renvoyer dans les cordes par
la justice ce que je crois c'est qu'il
faut avoir toujours présent à l'esprit
l'idée que nous vivons dans un état de
droit et que nos ennemis qu'il faut
nommer maintenant et je crois qu'il faut
non seulement une réaction mais des
actions ne respecte pas cet état de
droit moi je crois une chose assez
simple et je me dis qu'une fois qu'on
leur a comprises
nous aurons fait un grand pas en avant
c'est que beaucoup de ceux qui nous
attaquent parmi les terroristes
islamistes
qu'est ce qu'ils souhaitent sont pas
tous des équilibres et ils sont pas tous
fous je crois qu'ils veulent faire de la
france une république islamique
une fois qu'on aura compris ça je crois
qu'on saura utiliser les bons moyens
alors j'entendais la chronique de mon
voisin j'ai dit que nous vivions dans un
état de droit et le gouvernement
respectera le droit maintenant que l'on
dit sol que l'on pense à dissoudre des
associations qui ont des liens avec le
terrorisme islamiste
ça me paraît être ça me paraît aller
dans la bonne direction et on en a déjà
dissous peut-être je crois plus d'une
dizaine sous le mandat
des manuels mâcon et c'est une direction
quant à l'expulsion des fiches et s
puisque ils ont été évoqués je crois
effectivement que nos concitoyens ne
comprennent pas que des fiches et s est
rangée même en situation régulière sur
le territoire français ne soient pas
expulsés
moi je crois que s'ils menacent l'ordre
public et doivent l'être
après c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours des
difficultés concrètes de laisser passer
parce que les états peuvent refuser le
retour sur leur territoire de leurs
propres ressortissants là à ce moment là
il y a aussi les pressions diplomatiques
et je crois qu'il faut savoir en faire
usage parce que c'est le respect notre
ordre public qui est en jeu et il y a
moyen de faire pression sur les états
qui ne veulent pas récupérer leurs
ressortissants qui reconnaissent à vous
connaissez bien ces différentes
associations qui est qui sont ciblés il
va falloir rassembler des preuves contre
ces associations pour pouvoir les 10
août pour pouvoir étayer ses ces
décisions or ces associations elles sont
assez légaliste globalement elles font
attention à pas franchir la ligne rouge
comment comment faire dans ces cas là
moi je suis frappé un je reviendrai sur
l'attentât que nous venons de subir de
la connaissance juridique des failles de
notre système
bon le ccf par exemple qui est une
association kojève le personnellement
l'occasion de présenter de fréquentes et
très très près si vous voulez est une
association qui se caractérise par le
fait que auquel l'a jamais fait un
communiqué condamnant un attentat
terroriste jamais même le dernier le
dernier communiqué j'ai encore regardé
ce matin c'est l'heure est au silence et
recueillement lit le nom de samuel petit
et que je sois un bon donc si vous
voulez c'est une association je devais
appeler une audi dont une seule nous
intéresse les actes islamophobes
j'avais dit mais le jour où vous avez un
juif intégré c'est un musulman radical
qui sape sur la figure comment fait-on
c'est de l'antisémitisme ou c'est de
l'islamophobie
donc ils sont dans une espèce de système
fermé et ça va donc être extrêmement
difficile de les de les faire
disparaître parce qu'encore une fois
peut-être qui ne dit rien consent mais
en droit c'est pas suffisant
le point qui me frappe le plus si vous
voulez c'est la méthodologie de cet
attentat la notamment au regard du droit
civil et on a connu l'époque dahesh les
gros attentats de masse organisées de la
logistique etc
ensuite on a connu il avait après la
disparition de dèche
terrorisme en de gamme avec des jeunes
français musulmans ou convertis bon ça
ce sont des choses que les services
services de renseignement et la justice
peut poursuivre mais regardez le cas ici
on a un fait générateur en l'occurrence
il se trouve la jeune fille qui dénonce
un professeur babacaud qu'elle n'a pas
assisté mais ça suffit a allumé la mèche
le père va s'adresser non pas à
l'association de parents d'élèves du
quartier mais va s'adresser tout utah
zekraoui qui est un type un imam connu
qui a déjà un casier judiciaire
extrêmement lourd il s'est en
particulier attaqué à une mosquée
la mosquée de chalghoumi dans laquelle
ils ont cassé bon on se dit quand même
c'est assez étonnant qu'il n'y a aucune
suite judiciaire ça et donc lui va aller
chez le proviseur chez le chef
d'établissement
et puis il va faire comme si la chose
était réglé et donc le chef
d'établissement finalement éteint le
voyant rouge mais que dès qu'ils
rentrent chez lui il commence à faire
l'interview de la jeune fille et ilham
et sur les réseaux sociaux il allume
tout le collectif qui ensuite va faire
tous ces menaces toutes ces différentes
8 et vous avez ne serait-ce que prenant
le cas de millas avec mila on a vu
trente mille tweets contre cette jeune
fille comment voulez vous que la police
pour suivre et ensuite quand vous avez
le déroulement de l'attentât lui-même
vous dit attendez il ya celui qui la
véhiculent hélas celui qui la commune à
rouen il ya celui qui l'a aidé à acheter
des arbres afin d arme un couteau c'est
pas cher mais ne confondons pas et et
puis vous avez toute cette suite ça mais
pour le pénal c'est très difficile d'en
suite d'aboutir à quelque chose qui soit
l'association effective avec l'attentât
terroriste fait défaut c'est là qu'il
faut adapter notre droit à ces nouveaux
outils que sont les réseaux sociaux en
l'occurrence haut niveau il faut aussi
adopter la jurisprudence on est dans le
plein procès de du réseau de soutien des
attentats de 2005
donc on va voir quelle condamnation va
sortir mais là il ya une jurisprudence
qui est en train de se créer donc là il
ya effectivement quelque chose qui va
étendre si vous voulez le champ de la
responsabilité et c'est ça la véritable
transformation qui doit se passer
aujourd'hui les lois existent c'est vrai
les lois existent mais par exemple vous
faisiez allusion à la sphère de mila
c'est vrai que réduire l'anonymisation
ce serait quand même déjà une bonne
chose et les services de police avaient
déjà et heureusement ils ont la
possibilité d'obtenir générait l'alleud
de cet anonymat et il connaissait
beaucoup des pseudos qui s'étaient
exprimés je crois qu'il faut leur donner
les moyens de pouvoir réagir mieux parce
que cette petite mila aujourd'hui vit
dans des conditions absolument
effroyable et il me semble me souvenir
que la réaction avait été assez lente
assez lente il ya eu 3 quand même alpha
que c'est le cadre d'un mot de votre
côté comment vous jugez la situation est
ce que nos démocraties vous semblent
suffisamment armées pour faire face pour
mener ce type de combat face aux
islamistes
je ne suis pas spécialiste de cette
mécanique judiciaire
mais ce qui est le plus extraordinaire
c'est la chaîne l'écosystème qui a
abouti à l'assassinât la décapitation de
monsieur pâtit je viens d'être rappelé
c'est d'une certaine manière tout un
quartier qui va de l'école à la mosquée
à des gens qui regardent qui sont plutôt
favorables à cela des protestations
c'est à dire que si on n'arrive pas à
modifier en profondeur
l'état d'esprit c'est à dire là le
rapport qu'ont ces gens avec la
république et ses lois alors l'avenir
restera extrêmement difficile le
problème qui est vraiment fondamental
j'ai raison mais vous avez raison mais
ça fait si longtemps que nous avons
laissé peu à peu au prétexte de laisser
s'exercer les libertés individuelles
il ya eu des légendes des
décolonisations ce que nous avons été
assez lâches et qu'aujourd'hui nous
subissons ces conséquences parce que
nous avons laissé peu à peu grignoté les
valeurs essentielles de notre république
et nous en sommes tous responsables si
nous ne réagissons pas collectivement
dans tous les services publics concernés
là nous pouvons que réagir et dans
toutes les associations qui sont
culturels alors que elle devrait être
cultuel et je crois que le problème le
texte qui est en préparation et qui a
pour objectif de circonscrire comme il
se doit les associations qui relaie
de la loi de 1901 ou celles qui relèvent
de la loi de 1905
on aura beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
progressé parce que nous allons assister
à cette espèce de mélange des genres qui
fait qu'en réalité le cultuel fait du
socioculturel et il ça ne va pas et
bénéficie de subventions de l'état très
conséquente
tout cela doit être reconsidéré et de
façon très ferme et reconnaissez à c'est
quoi le problème aujourd'hui c'est un
problème de droit
on a les outils juridiques ou pas pour
faire face à cette situation moi j'ai le
sentiment que les outils que les outils
juridiques existent je vais vous prendre
un exemple le droit d'asile le droit
d'asile donc aujourd'hui enfin à sont
d'origine canton si les conventions et
les années 50 tout le monde se reproche
d'avoir refusé les juifs apatrides que
hitler avait renvoyé mois donc on a fait
un texte qui est très protecteur qui
interdit de faire des apatrides et c'est
la première vague ce sont les réfugiés
europe de l'est c'est à dire des
défenseurs des libertés
et puis ensuite aux arts au tournant des
années 80 on commence à accueillir des
islamistes algériens parce que
persécutées par leur gouvernement
quand même assez facile il est par
contre des intellectuels qui était
menacé par les islamistes on leur refuse
le droit d'asile
donc la jurisprudence va s'adapter mais
reprenons le cas anglais le cas anglais
être extrêmement intéressant parce que
heroes accueille des islamistes
poursuivie chez eux pour faits de
violence et qui vont accueillir à
londres avec le civisme britannique
c'est oui mais toute façon ça ça nous
permet de les surveiller les attentats
blonde tout à coup le système bascule à
180 degrés il négocie directement avec
le yémen la jordanie etc pour leur
renvoyer leur réussissent labiste la
seule condition c'est qu'il ne soit pas
condamné à mort je veux dire c'est quand
même du réalisme c'est pas du débat
juridique c'est à dire que les moyens
diplomatiques que vous évoquez thaler
sont parfaitement possible mais il faut
se mettre dans une position de force
c'est à dire on coupe les vivres en
coupe les aime sommes dans un rapport de
force
oui mais il faudrait être dans une
position de force c'est à dire pas à mes
raisons mais je crois qu'il ya des
tabous il y avait des tabous sur
lesquels nous sommes prêts sans doute à
revenir et vous faisiez allusion au
droit d'asile oui la politique de
l'immigration dans son ensemble
d'ailleurs classique ou droit d'asile je
crois qu'elle doit être revue ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il faut cesser bien entendu
mais elle doit être revue à la lumière
d'un contexte qui complètement différent
sap a été établi comme l'un des
priorités aujourd'hui par emmanuel
macron en tout cas
le sujet n'est plus tabou
le sujet n'est plus tabou et il a été
évoqué et il a été évoqué aussi par le
garde des sceaux par le ministre de
l'intérieur et je crois qu'on ne doit
pas se l'interdire et je crois qu'il
faut aussi que nous réfléchissions
beaucoup à la frontière ténue qui existe
entre islam islamisme c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
beaucoup on souffre beaucoup
d'ambiguïtés que nous avons laissé se
développer sur ce sur ce registre etc
certes différents mais ya pas de
solution de continuité non plus j'en
crois que ce sont des sujets qui ne sont
plus tabous et ça c'est un grand pas en
avant
j'aimerais quand même qu'on s'arrête sur
la question des réseaux sociaux parce
que vous l'avez vous avez évoqué cet
enchaînement qui s'est produit dans le
cas de l'assassinât de ce professeur
d'histoire géographie samuel pâtit et on
a vu une fois de plus comment les
réseaux sociaux arrivent à attiser la
haine a enflammé d'un coup toute une
communauté
vous avez évoqué le problème de
l'anonymat là ça n'aurait rien réglé de
lever l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux
donc comment appréhender cette
problématique là des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui moi je suis pas d'accord
avec vous s'il a mené au moins les gens
se lancer dans des menaces de mort non
non ça c'est vous pensez que vous pensez
que le terrorisme ne serait pas passé à
l'acte
ah non non c'est pas ça c'est qu'on
n'aurait probablement pas eu cette
émulsion tout à coup de gens qui se sont
sentis saisi d'une information qui était
faut en changer encore n'oublions pas ça
et donc il serait hors était beaucoup
moins courageux si vous voulez donc sur
le fond simplement négocier avec les
gars femmes qui ont parfois la taille
d'un état de taille moyenne c'est
quasiment impossible et on est dans le
droit américain adam américain et
considère qu'il n'y a pas de censure
possible sur la liberté d'information
utile européenne tout cela a été long
bref c'est vrai que quand on sait les
faibles moyens de faro si on se dit que
il faudrait mettre quand même augmenter
considérablement les moyens
je pensais bien vous savez à l'époque de
mera les fichiers s je crois qu'ils
étaient 2500 aujourd'hui on est à 18000
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on repère mieux où ça veut dire qu'il
ya plus moi j'ai tendance à penser que
c'est le deuxième la deuxième version
donc si on est face à ce mouvement
croissant il est évident qu'on ne peut
pas augmenter les effectifs de police à
due proportion donc le seul moyen c'est
de vider le stock et donc il faut
trouver les moyens de vider le stock
c'est à dire effectivement d'aboutir à
des expulsions
avec des négociations diplomatiques et
comment dire des pressions diplomatiques
très forte il ya beaucoup de pays qui
attendent de l'aide si vous voulez de la
france au moins cela on peut leur
envoyer ainsi des moyens classiques de
lutte et agir sur le trafic de
stupéfiants par exemple qui est un
substrat économique très conséquents
pour le séparatisme très conséquent
culturellement et socio économiquement
si je puis dire donc ce sont des
registres sur lesquels on peut agir d'un
mot juste très vite pour conclure je
m'adresse à l'ancienne magistrate qu'est
ce qui empêchera une association
dissoute de se recréer sous un autre nom
j'ai envie de vous dire que ça n'est pas
possible de répondre en un mot cette
prise de conscience qui est la nôtre et
la défense des valeurs républicaines
part je dirais l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale
rien d'autre merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'être venu sur notre plateau
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau ça vous
regarde tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire sur lcp
à bientôt
[Musique]